>> Hello, my name is Bono.
I'm a rock star, sort of and, umm, yeah.
I think there's something everybody can do
and I won't tell, umm, I
won't tell you where you can hook up to fight
against extreme poverty
in your own neighborhood 'cause I don't know
what the organizations
are but you can find them out.
But I will say this: In 2008 if we're to get
anywhere, umm, on the
fight against extreme poverty or the climate
crisis, we have to prove
that we can keep the promises that we've already
made.
So we call them the millennium development
goals and right now
politicians are slipping back in their commitments
to half extreme
poverty by 2015 so my message to you today
is do not let them and, uh,
I love that line, uh, of Tom Freedman's about
climate change: Don't
change your lightbulbs.
Change your leaders.
Thank you.
Bye.